philippe bélair bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france pour
commencer qu est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire de la situation sur place à 7
heures bonjour d'abord laissez-moi faire
un point s'il vous plaît un préalable
lorsque les choses partent dans tous les
sens il faut souligner que notre
organisation syndicale et tout le
mouvement anti passe sanitaire qui qui
existent en guadeloupe n'a rien d'anti
vaccin contrairement à ce qu'on dit n'a
rien d'anti science et nous ne sommes
pas dans le déni de la circulation du
virus
quand les choses soient très claires
d'accord donc la situation effectivement
les critiques elle est critique pour
mais nous n'avons pas la même lecture
que les autorités pour nous elle est
critique parce que tout simplement le
gouvernement a fait les mauvais choix
nous nous gardons notre cas et notre
analyse est toujours la même
2 plein début le gouvernement c'est de
les mauvais choix dès le 10 par an il ya
aujourd'hui nous payons les conséquences
c'est-à-dire un moyen très honnêtement
complètement mais là si tu as le la le
fait que le delta circulent aujourd'hui
il faut regarder ça dans quelques
perspectives
la première c'est que avant le moal à la
fin du mois du mois de juin n'étions pas
dans cette situation ils ont fait le
choix d'ouvrir les frontières avec cinq
ou six porteurs par bonjour et avec
effectivement des gens non vaccinés et
vaccinés aujourd'hui nous nous trouvons
dans une situation où il y à un conflit
entre les autochtones et les personnes
qui arrivent qui se disent lac signer
mais qui ne prennent pas de précautions
ça montre qu'on croise en mode que le
gouvernement joue la division de la
population entre les vacciner les non
vaccinés les autochtones ceux qui
viennent de
l'extérieur bref le gouvernement ne
prend pas ne cible pas l'expérience
antérieure le gouvernement n'a qu'une
seule chose en tête et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ce qui compte pour eux c'est
de déposer déposer une seule est une et
un seul humain est une ex fois qu'elle
en politique c'est à dire une injection
et rennes alors qu'il y à d'autres
possibilités alors en tout cas le
ministre d outre-mer sébastien lecornu a
annoncé sa venue aux antilles dès demain
qu'est ce que vous attendez vous de
cette visite
rien du tout absolument rien du tout je
nous avons entendu dire qu'il y ait qu
il y aurait deux sens 40 250 francs
voilà qui arrive c'est très bien c'est
très bien mais par contre on aurait dû y
penser bien avant je vois appel qu'en
2010 19 nous avons mené une grève très
d'être cadieux de deux ou trois mois
pour avoir des moyens en personnels
après cette grève et après l'expérience
que vit le début de 20 beaucoup de
collègues ont démissionné beaucoup de
collègues sont à plat aujourd'hui le
manque de personnel se fait ressentir
et aujourd'hui les autorités jouent la
catastrophe
au regard du fait que justement nous
sommes en manque de personnel est ce que
ces 240 personnels soignants justement
attendu est-ce que ça vous paraît
suffisant comme non parce que il faut
plus de moyens aujourd'hui au vu de la
situation dans les hôpitaux
écouter de manière générale il faut plus
de monde
ces gens là veulent absolument nous
faire vider insu un flux d'eau avec un
petit verre de cognac c'est pas possible
ça c'est pas possible il faut qu'on
arrête ce petit jeu-là ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est de comprendre à qui et
que la situation
c'est conjoncturel en fait c'est
conjoncturel ils vont venir en 204 240
250 personnes vont en venir mais c'est
conjoncturel
or le problème structurel le problème
est structurel depuis tantôt depuis des
années on a détruit le services publics
de santé et aujourd'hui on en paye les
conséquences
et je dois vous dire que nous sommes en
période de cyclone il paraît que la
seule option possible
c'est ce vaccin est belle mais
j'aimerais savoir s'il y a une
catastrophe cyclonique est ce qu'il y à
un vaccin tout ça d'accord il y at il un
vaccin tout ça les gens ne comprennent
pas qu'il faut arrêter ce délit ou il
faut expo il faut mettre sur la table
toute la panoplie nécessaire tout l'été
à toutes les actions thérapeutiques
possibles et laisser les gens faire leur
choix
il y a un doute ton certaines personnes
sur l'éjection arn il faut le comprendre
pourquoi diable veto absolument imposer
ça n'a pas de sens on n'est plus dans
une gestion sanitaire on est dans une
gestion idéologique
alors lorsque je vous rappelle que nous
nous demandions des millions 1 il aura
fallu ils nous refusent les millions
pour avoir les moyens
or aujourd'hui il les lois il aura fallu
simplement des milliards pour pouvoir
investir dans ces vaccins alors comme
moyen en tout cas aujourd'hui proposée
par le gouvernement
il y a cette vaccination on en est où
actuellement guadeloupe il ya à peine 10
% de la population qui qui est qu'ils
acceptent cette vaccination
ce n'est pas pas contrairement à ce qui
est dit souvent j'entends des niaiseries
[Musique]
au niveau national nous traitant de vos
dix ans de l'alcoolique et de
catholiques
fin bref de toutes sortes de noms
d'oiseaux
non nous ne sommes pas ce stade là les
gens sont une expérience passée il faut
alors il faut se rappeler que nous
sommes dans un pays qui a un certain
nombre de problèmes d'eau un certain
nombre de problèmes
conséquemment à l'utilisation de
l'aplomb du cône
les gens sont très méfiants aujourd'hui
il ya une bonne quinzaine méfiance
vis-à-vis de ce que le gouvernement
propose comme alors qu'il y a
d'autres solutions possibles il suffit
de laisser le choix aux gens et tout ira
bien
tout ira bien les gens ne sont pas bêtes
les gens savent mais ils ont ils ont le
droit de choisir
merci philippe bélair d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce soir sur un ton
franc je le rappelle vous êtes le
secrétaire général de la cgtg santé
guadeloupe